(alarm sounds)
- That was super, super ridiculously sour.
- I thought it would
be a really funny idea
to go around the office
and test people's sour candy threshold,
so I went looking for the
sourest candy in the world.
I couldn't get my hands on it,
but I found the next best
thing, these bad boys.
They're actually from the U.K.
They're not even available in the U.S.
So, I'm gonna go around and see
what people think; let's go.
What's your relationship with sour candy?
Do you like it?
- I usually like sour candy,
not like crazy sour stuff.
- You know, I'm very sensitive to it.
- I don't know why people put
themselves through the pain.
- Sour candy, first of all,
should not be called sour candy.
It should just be called
sour pieces of (beep).
- I can't stand sour candy.
- You don't like sour candy?
- Not at all.
I find it extremely painful,
and it hurts my whole mouth.
- I used to love sour candy,
but now I'm afraid of it.
- [Voiceover] I'm scared now.
- It looks like a tiny,
pink munchkin doughnut.
- A large marble.
- It looks like a bouncy ball
that's been coated in illegal (beep).
- It's pretending to be
sweet, but it's like poison.
- This is safe, though, right?
- One, two, three.
(laughs)
(dramatic music)
- I thought we were friends!
- They're like a warhead on steroids.
- If you swallow it, it burns your throat.
- It's like when they put
the vacuum in your mouth
at the dentist's to suck
all the moisture out.
That's what's going on with this.
- It's like battery acid.
- It tastes like what I
imagine cleaning fluid
to taste like.
- Detergent!
- It tastes like a punishment!
- It tastes like someone shot
a machine gun in my face!
- Is there a hole in my tongue?
- I got through it and then I bit into it,
and then it started foaming,
and I felt like I had rabies.
- I spit it out in my cup of water,
and it's like fizzing in here.
That's what it's doing in
your stomach right now.
- Yeah, it's pretty sour.
Its NBD, though.
- NBD.
Okay, I was told by my colleagues
that it's only fair
that I try this as well.
Mmm, uhh, mmm, mmm.
Mmm.
(perky music)